the third to last class. Uh, your
project is due next Monday. Numbers are
due Sunday. So, by now you've heard that
enough times from me. Um, couple of
things on the project. One is, and I've
said this before, this is not just about
presenting the numbers you get on your
company because that comes out of a
spreadsheet. It's reading those numbers
and telling me what I mean, basically,
you're spinning a narrative for your
company. What does it do well? What does
it do badly? What could it do better?
Right? And don't make up things that it
can do better just to make up things. If
it does everything well, just say that's
what it does. So, that's basically what
I'm looking for in the project. Any
questions in the logistics of the
project of the final
exam?
Okay, so let's talk about where we left
off. We're talking about BP, right? Had
a dividend problem and eventually it
came to a head. They had to cut
dividends and the stock price dropped.
But if you think about why the problem
became as big as it did, it's because
they didn't deal with it early enough.
if they had dealt with it in 85 or 86 or
87, it wouldn't have come to an end. So,
let's talk a little bit about companies
that get into a dividend problem and
perhaps manage it a little better than
BP. So, I'm going to start with the
study that looked at dividend cuts.
We've all agreed that dividend cuts tend
to send a signal to the market. The
market reacts badly. Is there a way you
can package a dividend cut to make it
more palatable to the market? So, what
the study looked at was companies that
announced a dividend cut with other
actions that go with it. Because you
almost never get a company saying,
"We're going to cut dividends." It's
usually other news that goes with it.
Let's start with the first one. You have
a dividend cut and it comes with an
announcement that earnings are also
down. What do you when when you're an
investor in the market, the company cuts
dividends, the earnings are also down.
Of course, you're going to assume the
worst. So, the stock price is down and
it stays down for the announcement
period. But in the quarter
after it does bounce back a little bit.
If you have a prior announcement of an
earnings decline, it continues into the
announcement period, but the quarter
after again you see a bounce back. But
if you have a dividend cut that your
company with other things you plan to
do. So let's say you're cutting
dividends not because you're going
through a bad period. Your earnings are
down but because you have investments
you have to make. Remember that company
that got into a dividend prom because
the business itself had changed. You
need to package the dividend cut with
something else. In this case, say look,
these are the things we want to invest
it in and hope that the market
eventually comes to its senses.
Initially, the market still reacts
badly, but if you look at the quarter
after, you see a much bigger bounce back
if there is in fact something else
you're going to use the dividend for.
So, there's you can't package this any
better. I mean, when you have a dividend
cut, it's always going to be a negative
reaction. That's almost a given. It's
what you can do afterwards that you're
looking forward towards. So let's look
what at at a couple of final examples
and we'll wrap up dividend
policy. During this period 1992, the
limited was still this high growth
retail firm. It's kind of laughable when
you look back that the limited and the
gap used to be high growth companies.
The limit was a high growth company and
between 1983 and '92 its free cash flow
equity on average was minus $34 million
a year. Let me pause right there. If you
have a company with negative free cash
flow equity and asked you how much
should this company pay in dividends,
the answer is it shouldn't pay
dividends. It's a great growth company
of great projects. Why would it? But if
you look at the limited on average it
paid about $41 million in dividends.
Now, I don't know the inside story, but
I'm going to at least guess on how the
limited got into this pathway. Somewhere
early in this
game, you know, they had negative free
cash equity and they're visited by a
banker and that's never good news. And
the banker says, "Look, you're not
paying dividends and if you don't pay
dividends, there are some investors who
cannot buy your stock." Is that true?
Yeah. There's some pension funds that
are restricted to buying only dividend
paying companies.
So here's what the banker says. Pay a
little bit in dividend, a token
dividend, because then it'll allow those
investors to buy your stock. It'll
increase the demand for your stock and
push up the stock
price. Sounds alluring,
right? Would you fall for it? What's
What's the problem with paying just a
token
dividend? How do I describe those people
who bought BP
stock? Dividend addicts, right? What
happens when you give an addict a
token shot? It never stays a token shot,
right? They come in, you give them the
token, they want more dividends and
still more. The limited started paying a
million dollars in dividends. The token
div by the end of the period, they were
paying $50 million in dividends. If you
can't afford to pay dividends, don't
open the door to investors who like
dividends. They're not suited for your
company. So as you look at companies
that have negative free cash flow equity
that start paying dividends no matter
how good the reason it doesn't make
sense because you're attracting an
investor clientele that's unsuited for
your
company. So why do you think Facebook
and Google you know started paying
dividends this year? Are they trying
to existing investors probably don't
like it right but what are they trying
to do you think by starting this
dividend
policy? I think they're trying to change
their dividend clientele. I think they
want a different investor base going
forward. And it's a good healthy thing
to start the process and you control the
process. Final example is starter motors
part of a family group, right? If you
look at their free cash or equity, it's
actually negative. And even if you bring
in the debt, you're basically looking
at, you know, the at least without the
debt a a huge negative free cash flow
equity. With the target debt ratio, it's
about 48
million. Their actual dividends plus
buybacks is 75 million. Again, like the
capital structure where we found Tarta
Motors was over 11. It looks like Tata
Motors is paying a little too much in
dividends, at least relative to three
cash equity. Now that might be here by
design, but they're not underleveled. So
you can't say they're using the debt to
push towards a target debt ratio. But
just as with capital structure with
family group companies, it becomes
difficult to decide whether the company
is doing something that doesn't make
sense or whether it's doing something
that advances the interest of the family
group. Let's say the Tata Group, right?
You might want to take cash out of
companies that you think are not high
growth promising companies and put them
into companies that have much better
prospects. For the Tata Group, that was
starter consulting services where the
growth and the returns were. So for all
you know, they're using this company as
a way of channeling cash out of low
growth companies into higher growth
companies. You create an internal
capital market. The only problem is
these are all independent companies and
the shareholders essentially are seeing
wealth transfer from one company to
another. So with the each of the
companies basically we follow the same
path. We look at the free cash rate
equity, we look at the dividends, we
look at the quality of projects and we
make a judgment. So if I were to put my
five companies on a matrix, here's what
they would where they would stand.
BU has cash surplus, pays no dividends,
but it's probably going to be left
alone. It's a company with great great
returns. Deutsche Bank has a cash
deficit and has poor projects. This is
your worst possible scenario. You don't
even know where to start cuz clearly the
company has an operating problem. Now,
the three companies all bundled
together. They have decent projects, but
they're returning too much cash and some
because of buybacks in the case of
Disney. And that's going to be easier to
fix. Just buy back less stock. Some
because they pay high dividends and
that's going to be tougher to change
because people get used to dividend
policy. So for each of your companies,
that's going to be the dividend section.
You're going to start by looking at what
your company has actually paid out
dividends and live tax. And the answer
might be nothing like
BU. Then you're going to look at what
they could have returned the free cash
or equity. And my suggestion as I said
in the last session is to do it over a
period 5 years 10 years so you can see
what the aggregated values look like.
And then I'm going to ask you a
question. Do you trust the management of
this company? What kind of projects does
it have? It's a subjective judgment. But
by now you've already done the
investment analysis, the capital
structure section. You should have the
ammunition to say I trust my company
with my cash. And if the answer is you
trust the company, just let it go. If
you don't, then at least alert the
company to the fact that investors might
start to demand that cash
back. Any questions on dividend policy,
any aspect of
it? Now, of course, like capital
structure, the most common way in which
companies set dividends is by looking at
the rest of the peer group. So, what
I've done here is looked at the dividend
yield and payout ratio for my five
companies relative to my comparable
group. And I've defined my comparable
group group in terms of yield and
payout. So if you look at Disney 1.09%
dividend yield, the pure group is 0.96%.
Payout ratio of about
22%. Looks like very much like Disney is
keeping up with that pure group. Right?
If you look at Valle, if you look across
the board, you can see that they all
have the same issues. high dividend
deals, high payout ratios because
commodity prices were down across the
board and they were all doing the same
thing, which is paying dividends and
hoping that earnings would bounce back.
For Tata Motors, the payout and the
dividend yield were lower than for the
pure group, which kind of makes sense
because they're an Indian automobile
company. Maybe they see more growth
prospects, but already you can see even
within pure groups, you might want to
control for differences between your
company and the peer group. DOA of
course is a disaster in a sector full of
disasters. So I don't even know what to
say when you're paying out 360% of your
earnings as dividends. But that's what
happens when you get stuck with a
dividend policy set way back in time
when you were a much better company. You
know how to get out of it,
right? With Disney though, I did take a
closer look at the pure group because
it's such a diverse group. You have
small companies, big companies. In fact,
Disney and time want to kind of stand
out in this group. So, I wanted to see
what and you can see the differences in
dividend yield and payout ratios across
even the peer group. Remember with the
capital structure, we looked at what
caused differences in debt ratios. You
can do the same thing with dividend
yields and payout ratios. What causes
differences in yields and payout ratios?
You can look at growth rates and you
know how risky the company is. So, as
with capital structure, the last thing I
did was I looked at all US companies,
the 2013 uh 2014 number, but you can get
the 2025 numbers if you're interested
across the entire US market. In other
words, I looked at what drives
differences in dividend yield and
dividend payout ratio across the market.
And the variables I used, I think make
sense. I looked at beta. High risk
companies should have lower dividends. I
looked at growth. high growth company
should have lower dividends. And I also
looked at how much they had as debt
because if you have a lot of debt, maybe
that also means you have higher cash
flows and you can pay more in dividends.
And it turns out that all of those
variables explain differences in
dividend yield to different degrees.
Okay? And if you plug in Disney's
numbers into the payout and yield, you
get an
estimated mark. So their actual market
debt is is 11.58. But if you plug in the
numbers into their predicted payout
ratios, you get predicted payout of 27%,
predicted yield of 1.4%, which is pretty
close to where they are. So my
conclusion is given how other companies
in the US are paying dividends. Disney's
yield and payout ratio look consistent
with the rest of the market. So kind of
an expanded peer group
discussion, which brings me to the last
part of this class. through all of this
class, what do we say the objective in
corporate finance is maximize the value
of the company, right? But we've really
never grappled with valuing an entire
company. We kind of in capital
budgeting, but we've never actually
valued an entire company. So, I'm going
to start with a quote from Oscar Wild,
which I think cuts to the heart of what
we'll talk about as value versus price.
He described a
cynic as a person who knows the price of
everything and the value of nothing. You
can replace the word cynic with a trader
and you could probably make the same
statement. Traders know the price of
everything. They know the value of
nothing. But it doesn't matter. They
trade on the price. So I want to spend
the rest of this class kind of filling
in that last gap. What is it that drives
value? How do all of the things we've
talked about in corporate finance play
out in that value? So, we're going back
to the top again. We started with
maximizing the value of the firm as an
objective. Let's go back and talk about
what it is that drives the value of a
company. I know how many of you in my
valuation class as well. I know quite a
few are. So, I'm going to give a
compressed version of my valuation
class. And the reason I'm going to give
you a compressed version is as some of
you have heard I am going to be on
sabbatical next year. And I'll I'll also
tell you why I'm on sbatical. It's, you
know, usually people take sbaticals to
write a book or do serious research. I'm
not interested in writing another book.
I have no serious research to do. I'm
taking a sbatical because my daughter's
having a baby in a couple of weeks.
Actually, it's due next
Tuesdays and uh she's a school teacher,
so she can't really afford daycare. And
I'm going to be child
care specialist for a year. I'm really
looking forward to it. lots of diapers
to change but u I will not be so I
wanted to give you a compressed
valuation class in these in the next
session and a half you'll get a full
valuation class if you're interested
somebody will teach it but let's talk
about valuation
right I start my valuation class by
saying there are three ways you can
attach a number to something the first
is what is is what's called intrinsic
valuation you might see it called you
know called DCF but I'm going to talk
about it as intrinsic valuation you
value something based on its cash flows,
its growth, and its risk. The second way
you can attach a number to an asset is
by looking at what other people pay for
similar assets. It's called
pricing. If that sounds obscure, think
about how you decide how much to pay for
a house or an apartment. You look at
other apartments in the neighborhood,
look at what people pay for them, and
you decide how much to pay for your
house or apartment based on pricing.
95% of what you see called valuation out
there is pricing. So I'm going to draw a
distinction between those and I'm going
to talk primarily about valuation in
this class but you can fill in the gaps
on what would would somebody whose
interest in pricing look at. And the
third way you can put a number and this
is the part of valuation that's
relatively new. By relatively I mean 50
years old is you can attach an option
pricing value to an asset if it has a
contingent cash flow. I don't want to be
mysterious but let's say you're valuing
a young biotech company, young pharma
company. It's got a blockbuster drug
working its way through the pipeline.
Whether it makes money depends on
whether the drug gets approved. That's a
contingency. You can argue there's an
option in there. I'm going to focus
primarily on intrinsic value because the
end game in corporate finance is to
maximize the value of the
business. Now, if markets are efficient,
price and value should converge sooner
or later. You can say about maximizing
value. I'm hoping that the price catches
up, but you're hoping it might not
happen in the near term. So, you might
go out and do things that are right for
your company, but the market might
punish you. Conversely, you can go out
and do things that are wrong for your
company in terms of value and the market
could reward you. You could throw
billions of dollars into bad projects,
but because it's AI, your stock price
gets pushed up. So, as a manager, I
think your obligation is to maximize
value and then try to talk the market
into getting the price to be in sync
with the value. But there will be times
where you will do things that are right
for the company and they work out to not
increase the price. It's a tough call
because as a as a manager, you get
judged based on market price, not based
upon value. But you in in corporate
finance at least, the focus is to stay
on value. So let's set up the big
picture perspective here. We make
discounted cash flow valuation more
complicated than it needs to be. It
comes from that very first class we all
get in finance. The value of an asset is
the present value of the expected cash
flows in the asset. Right? So an
equation that's the entire theory for
the
class value of an asset is the present
value of the expected cash flows. The
numerator are expected cash flows not
best case not conservative but expected
cash flows and in the denominator is a
risk adjusted discount rate. So
ultimately the value of any business any
asset comes from its capacity to
generate cash flows. That's not
debatable right? I don't care whether
you're an AI business, a young business,
an old business. Ultimately, I value
based on your capacity to create cash
flows. Second, how quickly you can grow
those cash flows. And third, the risk in
those cash
flows. So, I know that we tend to think
in terms of discounted cash flow
valuation as a value of a business. But
there are two ways you can frame a
discounted cash flow valuation when
you're looking at a company. And if this
sounds familiar, it's because we also
did this when we did capital
budgeting. The first is you can focus on
just the equity cash
flows and discount them back at the rate
of return that equity investors want.
And by now we have a way of framing both
of those things. What do equity
investors require when they invest in a
company? It's a cost of equity. What are
the cash flows they get from a company?
Strictly speaking, dividends. But as we
said in the dividend analysis section,
it could be free cash flow to equity.
You discount cash flows to equity at the
cost of equity. You value the equity in
a business. But there's another way you
can approach valuation which I think is
more general. Rather than focusing on
just what equity investors get, you can
look at what both lenders and equity
investors get from a company. Let's play
out a game. You guys are going to lend
to the company. You're equity
investors. Equity investors get free
cash equity. Whatever cash is left over
after debt payments, what do lenders
get? They get interest payments. They
get principal payments. That collective
cash flow you get is called the free
cash flow to the firm. And if that is
the cash flow I'm discounting, the
discount rate I use should be the
weighted average of what you want, which
is the cost of equity, and what the
lenders want, which is the cost of debt.
That sound familiar? That's the cost of
capital. cash flows to the business
discounted back at the cost of capital
gives you the value of the entire
business. So let's set the structure up.
When you value equity, you're focused on
just the equity investors. You're
wearing
blinders. All you care about is is cash
flows to equity and the free cash equity
that we did in the dividend policy
section becomes the cash flow you're
looking at. You discount it back at the
cost of equity. You get a value of
equity in the business.
Now the only problem with free cash
equity is you're making judgments on
what capex and depreciation and working
capital will be and debt payments. So
the alternative the strict version of
the model is the dividend discount
model. It's the oldest discounted cash
flow model in use and it's an equity
valuation model. So that's the first
approach. The second approach you take
the cash flow to the firm pre-debt cash
flows. And I want to emphasize it's got
to be cash flows before debt payments
because lenders are now part of the
capital providers. You look at the
collective cash flow you get. You're
discounted back at the cost of capital.
What you get is the value of the entire
firm. I'm going to use both so you can
see them both play out. But they're both
perfectly acceptable approaches. And if
you do it right, you'll get the same
value for the equity whether you value
the equity directly or whether you value
the firm and subtract out the debt due
to the firm. So let's set the table.
Okay? You sit down to value business.
What are the drivers of value? First,
you're going to look at the existing
investments the business has made. Look
at the cash flows you get from those
businesses. So, if you've taken 10
projects, you have three products out
there. You look at the cash flows in
those
products. Second, you can look at the
value of growth you get as this company.
And I want to emphasize the word growth
by itself is neither good nor bad. It
has two effects. The positive effect is
growth increases your revenues and your
earnings. That's a good side. The bad
side of growth is you have to reinvest
to create that growth. You got to build
factories. You got to invest in R&D. So
the value of growth captures how much
growth will add or destroy in value as
you try to grow. Risk in a discounted
cash flow model shows up in only one
place. It's in the discount rate. People
don't like it, but that's where it's
focused. So if you're a riskier set of
cash flows, I'll use a higher discount
rate. And finally, one of the problems
you'll face when you value companies is
companies at least in theory can last
forever. And we can't estimate expected
cash flows forever. So we put closure in
the model by assuming that at some point
in time in the future, your company will
start to grow at a rate it can sustain
forever. You know what that buys you? It
buys you an infinite series in
mathematics. An infinite series in
mathematics. 200 years ago somebody
solved for the value of that series. It
becomes a terminal value equation. You
see it allows you to capture the present
value of cash flows beyond. We use this
even in the context of capital
budgeting. If you remember the Disney
theme park we got to year 10. So it can
go on and we used the terminal value
equation in discounted cash flow
valuation for companies. You almost
always have to bring that into play. So
cash flows from existing assets, value
of growth, risk and what happens in
steady
state. Now if you if most of you think
about valuation, you think of numbers in
a spreadsheet in big Excel spreadsheets,
especially if you worked at banks, these
spreadsheets can have, you know, 50
worksheets all connected to each other.
I'm going to kind of step back from that
and talk a little bit about something I
learned in the process of doing
valuation that has changed the way I
think about valuation.
In every valuation there are you know
there are stories people and number
people. Stories people tell you great
stories about the business. Numbers
people are the ones who grind through
the numbers putting growth rates and and
inputs into spreadsheets. A good
valuation is a bridge between stories
and
numbers. You're saying what does that
even mean? Take an example.
Uh now I valued Tesla just a couple you
know a few weeks ago and I gave Tesla
$500 billion in revenues in year 10. So
if you look at my Excel spreadsheet
there's 500 billion revenues. Let's say
you point to those revenues
say why why 500 billion I could give you
one answer which is an entirely
numerical answer and you say look I used
a 25% growth rate for the next 5 years
and 15% thereafter which tells you
absolutely nothing. You know why you
should be a little skeptical about the
500 billion
revenues? What's the largest automobile
company in the world in terms of
revenues right
now? Volkswagen and and and Toyota are
pretty close to each other about 300
billion revenues a piece. Already I'm
making Tesla larger than the largest
automobile company in the world today.
Right. I now the owner should now be on
me to be to explain how they get to 500
billion. They could stay an automobile
company but that'll require selling
about 15 million electric cars maybe
even 20 million electric cars which is
going to be a really hard push
especially because the portion of the
the car market that's electric cars is
small and even if it grows this will
require a huge market share and if you
bring BYD into the picture I don't think
they can pull it off.
Almost by definition, a $500 billion in
revenue story has to also bring in other
ways in which Tesla could make money.
And with
Tesla, those other ways start to
multiply, right? What are some of the
other ways Tesla could make money beyond
just selling electric
cars? And this is the most talked about
company. You probably read a tweet about
what they can
do. What are the other ways they could
potentially make money?
robotics, Optimus Ro. So that's it's way
out there, but you could argue and know
how would that turn become a money
maker. What would Tesla have to do with
robots for them to make money from
robots?
Either sell it to manufacturing
companies and companies that have a lot
of things that robots could do. So that
could be one. What
else? Yes. Battery. batteries in which
case they will sell their electric car
batteries into so that's expanding into
energy home batteries that you could use
so maybe there's an energy business
inside which they already have through
first solar they can expand that
business anything
else that's going to be interesting
right because if you become the default
network maybe at some point in times
even if you have other manufacturers
cars you might have to pay for charging
at at a Tesla n so there's is a charging
network. We're starting to multiply
business was one more which I've heard
automated and this becomes tricky right
so let's let's flesh that out what can
Tesla do let's say this becomes a
reality right how you know what would
Tesla need to do to actually make money
on what are the ways it can take
automated driving and make money to Uber
one is it can basically take the
existing ride sharing companies I took
an Uber home last night my I'd gotten at
3:00 in the morning. I feel a little
dazed. Um I took an Uber home and maybe
they will know make the cars they will
lease and split the proceeds with Uber
because remember one of the advantages
for a ride sharing company having an
automated driving car is where does most
of your affair go right
now? 80% goes to the driver. Right?
Without a driver, you can say the entire
100% comes to the right sharing company.
And Tesla can say it's our cars that are
allowing you to do it. We'll take
half. The the advantage to Tesla is the
right sharing business is a nasty
business. It's a logistics-driven
business. You got to deal with millions
of people with complaints. Yesterday, I
could see people at the airport
complaining to Lift, my car is not here.
I don't think Tesla wants to deal with
that. So the advantage of letting an
Uber or Lyft do it is you don't have to
deal with the logistics. You've taken an
existing right sharing company. You
might be able to split the capital
investment with that company, right? So
they could say, "Look, you take half and
I'll take half." So it might be an
easier way because there are people
argue that maybe Tesla can produce be
its own automated taxi company, but
that's going to require doing what Uber
does in addition to cars. So I can tell
you a story of a far, but that's the
kind of story you need to explain the
500 billion. I gave Tesla
16% I'm sorry, 12% margins. You give an
automobile company double-digit margins,
you're already pushing the limits of
what an automobile company can earn.
Why? Because you look at the median
operating margin for an automobile
company, it's about 4%, 5%, 6%. If
you're a mass market autom automobile
company, if you're a luxury auto
company, you can earn 12% 134. But with
the 500 billion in revenues, I've made
Tesla a mass market automobile company,
right? You can't be a BMW and get to a,
you know, 500 billion in revenues. So,
you're saying, how do you get to 12%
margins? Here, I need a story of some
part of Tesla's business, which is a
high margin business will allow them to
push up margins. There's a story I did
not hear as one of the other businesses,
but anybody here own a
Tesla.
Okay, don't worry. No, we're not going
to pick on you. This is not know this is
not that kind of class. But a Tesla
without its software becomes just a heap
of metal sitting in your garage. It's a
company without its software that
becomes useless. Right now the software
gets packaged with the car when you buy
the
car. But even right now there are
portions of the software that you can
pay extra. The automated driving right
now if you want to get that extra
package is I don't know how much it is
$99. Do you have a sense of what it
costs? $199 a a month. Wow. Okay. So,
but you can see at some point in time
you might get a basic software package
with your car and then get premium
add-ons. You see where this is going,
right? There might be a software
business in the side. The advantage of
software business is the unit economics.
We're going to talk a little bit about
this when we talk about estimating
margin of your company are are amazing
because you can sell the next unit cost
you nothing. Margins are 40 45 50%. I
think there's enough in Tesla's business
model that'll allow them to earn higher
margins on some aspect of the business.
Is this a big story? Absolutely. Half a
trillion dollars in revenues, 12%
margins. The rest of the story kind of
blends in there. But with that big
story, the value that I got for Tesla
was $155 per
share. This is a few weeks ago when it
was trading at $240 or $230 per share.
Just because you have a big story
doesn't mean you're going to be able to
justify the price. But your story has to
lead to So every number in your
valuation has to have a story attached
to
it. You can also tell big stories about
your company too, right? In which case
my job is to find a number that goes
with it. If you get a chance, you go to
my blog, I have a valuation of
Birkenstock. Anybody here own Birkens
own a Birkensto? Not shares. No, you Why
do you like Calab? Why do you like
Birkenstock?
That's the only I've never said they
look stylish is never the answer. They
look they're comfortable right now. So,
I'm going to for those of you in my
valuation class, forgive me for
repeating what I said, but Birkenstock
is 250 years old as a company. It was a
business started by a German shoe maker
in the late
1700s. And for the first 200 years of
its existence, it was sold primarily to
German. Now when you have foot problems,
you went into a into these. So these
clinics that treated foot problems,
that's basically where it was sold
through. And to show you how brand names
are created through a series of AC
accidents. In
1966, a German American tourist went
back to Germany and she had footprints
when she was in Germany. She wore
Birkenstock. She really liked them. She
went to the owner of Birkenstock and
said, "I'd like to take these shoes back
to LA because I think we could find a
market there." He was very resistant.
He's very German. He said, "No, no, we
don't do that." She said, "No, no, let
me take them back." She must have been
very convincing because he let her take
the shoes back to an LA store. And the
rest, as they say, is history cuz a
bunch of hippies walked into the store.
And remember the essence of being a
hippie is you did what you didn't want
to do what everybody else was doing. And
in the 60s everybody wore even to
baseball games and wear suits and get
dressed up and wear no shoes that were
uncomfortable. Said we don't want to do
that. Birkenstock became the symbol or
the emblem that hippies used in the 70s
said look we're we're not and that
caught on. So that was the start
building block for their branding.
1992, a 16-year-old model named Kate
Moss wore Birkenstock on a Vogue cover
and it took off on
campuses. Over time, celebrities adopted
Birkenstock. Steve Jobs wore Birkenstock
as Birkenstock went on sale for like
260,000 a few years
ago. So, all of this built up to a brand
name. Two years ago, Birkenstock went
public. And the big story about
Birkenstock is look at the branding is
going to affect
value. Celebrity advertising for free.
That's going to affect value. And about
10 years ago, Burkenstock got this
amazing
CEO. He came in because the family felt
that it wasn't getting the most out of
the company. They hired an outsider to
come in and he did amazing jobs, an
amazing job with the company basically
by connecting the brand name with other
brand names. There a Prada Birkenstock
you can buy. You can go check them out
on Google. It's like $1,500. He
connected with bigname companies. And he
brought growth back to the
company. I mean, what each of the things
I've just described, the brand name, the
celebrity
advertising, the fact that you have
great management would be viewed as
intangibles, right? The stories we tell.
So if you take a look at my blog, what
I've done is taken each of those stories
and said this is where it'll show up in
my valuation. The great management shows
up in a high revenue growth rate because
without them I think the growth would be
like 8%. With them it's closer to
22%. The great brand name shows up in a
high margin. Their margins are like 24%.
The typical apparel footwear company has
margins of about 14%.
Celebrity advertising shows up as a much
lower investment to get growth because
these companies to build brand name have
to pay people millions of dollars.
Birkenstock gets that for free. And as a
final bonus, in the summer before
Birkenstock went public, the Barbie
movie came
out. How many of you saw the Barbie
movie? Remember Barbie Wears Pink
Birkenstock? I know you don't remember,
but go watch the movie again. In the
summer after the Barbie movie came out,
Birkenstock sales jumped by 30% that
summer. So in my valuation, I did a
firstear jump in the revenues that the
Barbie buzz, every single story becomes
a number. So when you talk about
valuations being bridges between stories
and numbers, that's what we're talking
about. You tell me a big story about
your company, I'm looking for the number
that goes with that story. It makes
valuations far more disciplined and far
more connected to the business because
left to our own devices, we are going to
wallow in our own delusions. Each of us,
one part of this comes easier than the
other. Right? Some of us are more
naturally number crunchers, some of us
are more naturally storytellers. Left
your own devices, you're going to have
your delusions as a storyteller and
number crunch. And you hang out with
other people who think just like you,
they won't seem like delusions.
So as we go through this process, we'll
talk more specifically about connecting
stories, numbers, but every one of you
in turn evaluation of a company, whether
you like it or not, you're telling a
story about the company. So let's set
the process up. Let's look at the inputs
that drive value and start working on
these inputs. And as we go through,
you're going to see much of the dirty
work in estimating these numbers we've
already done in the context of something
else in corporate finance. So first
we're going to start by talking about
cash flows. Those cash flows can either
be before debt payments. It's cash flows
of firm or after debt payments. Cash
flows to
equity. They have to be after taxes and
after reinvestments. We'll talk about
how we bring them in. When we talk about
growth, the growth rate can either be an
equity income, net income, earnings per
share if you're looking at equity,
valuing the equity in a company, or they
can be an operating income, which is a
pre-debt earnings number.
The discount rate can either be a cost
of equity if you're focused on valuing
the equity in a company or a cost of
capital. And in both cases, eventually
you got to get to a point where you say,
"I'm willing to let the growth rate be
constant forever." And we'll talk about
the constraints on that growth rate and
how it feeds in through a terminal
value. What you get as a present value
will either be the value of equity if
you're discounting cash flows to equity
at the cost of equity or the value of
the entire business in terms of
operating assets. if you're discounting
cash flows of firm at the cost of
capital. So, I'm going to take each of
these inputs and use the companies that
I've been talking about all through this
class to talk about how those inputs
will play out. So, let's talk about cash
flows first. Cash flows can either be
cash flows to equity or cash flow to the
firm. If you're talking about cash flow
to equity, if you want to be lazy, you
can just go with dividends. After all,
that's your only cash flow that's
tangible. But as we saw in the dividend
section, at least with US companies,
increasingly cash is returned in the
form of stock buybacks. So you can take
dividends plus
buybacks. Alternatively, you can say I
don't trust managers return what they
can. If this looks familiar, that's my
free cash rate equity calculation that
we just did when we did dividends. So
that's how you can compute cash flows to
equity. If you're talking about cash
flow of the firm, it's a pre-debt cash
flow. So I can no longer start with net
income. I start with operating income,
earnings before interest in taxes. I act
like I pay taxes. And I'll talk a little
bit about what I mean by act like I pay
taxes on that operating income. It's
called an unlevered cash flow. I act
like I have no debt payments, no
interest expenses. I look at after tax
operating income. And from that, I
subtract out what I need to
reinvest. The first is capital
expenditures minus depreciation. The
same item you saw in the free cash flow
equity and change in working capital.
make up your mind early in the process
as to whether you're going to be looking
at equity or the firm because everything
you do through the process will be
driven by that choice you make. So I'm
going to start with dividends for
Deutsche Bank and contrast it with you
know later on with free cashros equity
for the same company. So for for in 2007
when I was valing Deutsche Bank they
were a healthy bank. They were a bank
that looked like they could sustain
themselves. I decided to be lazy and
focus just on dividends. They paid out
€2,146 million of dividends on net
income of 6.5 billion. So they paid
about a third of their net income out as
dividends. In my 2008 valuation, I'm I
assumed that the dividends were
reasonable and I could use the dividend
discount model. But I'm also going to
show my 2016 valuation where I'd lost
trust in Deutsche to be able to pay the
dividends that they did. By then their
free cash flow equity had melted down.
So I'll talk about when you can get away
using dividends and it's a very very
narrow set of companies where you can
use dividends and when you've got to
give up on dividends and look at
estimates of free cash equity for Tata
Motors I estimated the free cash equity
starting with net income. So I went back
five years started with net income.
There's capex depreci all of these items
come directly out of the statement of
cash flows. So I looked at, you know,
capex, depreciation, change in working
capital. That's my reinvestment.
Remember, debt pays for some of it. And
again, it varies across time, but the
total equity reinvestment they had over
the period was about 88% of their net
income. They're reinvesting about 88% of
their net income back from the business.
Again, I'm looking at the past. It's
telling me nothing about the future, but
this is going to become the ammunition I
use to forecast the future. So free cash
rate equity can focus either on
dividends or free cash
equity and if you focus on free cash
equity you're getting a measure of
potential
dividends for Disney I wanted to go the
firm valuation route so to estimate free
cash of the firm I started with
operating income and in 2013 I had to do
the adjustment for leases today
hopefully accountants are doing it for
you so you don't have to do the same
adjustment so if you don't trust
accountants you can go back to a pre-
lease operating income and do it
yourself, you'll get pretty much the
same answer. That's my operating income,
10,032. My tax rate for Disney and
remember we talked about the contrast
between effective tax rate and marginal
tax rate. When we did cost of debt,
which one did we say we always go with
when we do cost of debt? The marginal
because interest saves you tax as a
margin. Here, I'm going to suggest a
different rule. And here's why. I'm
looking at the tax rate that I'll pay on
all of my operating income. It's not
just on the next dollar. The effective
tax rate is like an average tax rate
across all of my income. So here, I
think you can stay with an effective tax
rate at least in the near term. So I'm
going to start with 31% as my tax rate.
Capex was 5,239 million. Depreciation
was 2192. So they've got about 3 billion
in net capex and working capital
increased by 103 million. So, let's work
out free cash flow of the firm. I start
with the 10,032. And here's where acting
like I'm paying taxes comes in. I don't
usually pay taxes on my operating
income. I get to subtract out interest
expenses, come up with the taxable
income, and then pay taxes. I'm going to
act like I have no interest expenses.
That's why it's called an unlevered cash
flow. You act like you have no interest
expenses, which means you pay the tax,
the effective tax rate on the tax on the
entire operating income. If you look at
what I pay in taxes here, it'll be far
greater than their actual taxes paid
because this is a hypothetical tax. So
start with the after tax operating
income. I subtract the net capex and
subtract the change in working capital.
My free cash flow to the firm is about
3.2 billion. That's what I'm left with
after taxes and after reinvestment. And
again here I'm going to do what I did
motors. I'm going to look at the
percentage of my after tax operating
income that I put back into the
business. Collectively, my net capex and
change in working capital is 3,732
million. That's what they reinvest in
the business as a percentage of my after
tax operate income. That's about 53
about 54%. Why do I care what a company
reinvests? Why am I looking at a
company's history of
reinvestment? No. Clearly, it takes away
from my cash flows. That's a bad thing.
It makes my cash flows
lower. But where will it come back into
play in a valuation? Let's say look at
you look at your company the last 10
years it's reinvesting nothing. That's
good from a cash flow perspective. But
when you project growth for this company
you're going to have to be much more
cautious. If you're not reinvesting,
you're not going to get growth. So this
becomes an input into how quickly a
company can grow. And that's why I'm
tracking how much both automotives and
Disney are reinvesting. So cash flows
are cash flows either after debt
payments if you're doing cash flow
equity or before debt payments if you're
doing free cash flow to the
firm. Discount rates almost everything
I'm going to say is should sound
familiar because the discount rates in
the perspective valuation are exactly
the same discount rates we talked about
in the context of corporate finance. So
if you think about the different ways in
which discount rates have played out in
this class in the investment analysis
class in the investment analysis section
what did the cost of capital what was
the role of the cost of capital when we
did capital
budgeting it became the hurdle rate on
whether to take an investment so we used
to decide whether investment doesn't
need the product then we got to capital
structure what is the role of the cost
of capital
Leon what the right it became an
optimizer too. Then we got to dividend
policy. What did the cost of capital
help us
do? We looked at the return on capital a
company earned and made less than the
cost of capital. We said this company
should be paying out more in dividends,
right? It became a divining rod in
dividends. Now we're in valuation. The
cost of capital becomes a rate of return
you will need to invest in the entire
company. It becomes a discount rate to
value the whole company. Four different
parts of corporate finance. Corporate
finance comes in cost of capital comes
in each part separately and that's why I
call it the Swiss army knife of finance.
It's always there used in different
context and you have to recognize where
it's being used. So cost of capital and
the cost of equity the intuitive
statement we made early on still stands.
Riskier cash flows should go with higher
cost of equity and higher cost of
capital.
started the class we weren't clear how
to measure risk but as we went through
we defined risk through the eyes of the
marginal investors with equity the beta
and the risk premium with cost of debt
we defined it through the default risk
and the default spread everything we
said there still applies the one thing
though that you have to recognize when
you do cost of equity and cost of
capital for an entire company is
companies can change over time unlike an
individual project where the project is
given companies can change over time and
because you're making those changes, you
should be consistent about what kind of
cost of capital you're using across
time. So, let's say you'reing a company,
it's entirely US-based company. Now, you
believe that over the next 10 years,
half of its revenues are going to come
from Latin
America. You know what your cost of
capital should do, right? When you
start, it should be based on a US equity
risk premium, but as you move through
time, your equity risk premium should
change reflect the geographies where
you're going to be investing. You're
valuing a company. It's in one business
now.
Pelaton mostly, you know, subscriptions,
fitness, equipment, but you think that
it can create a third business and you
put that into your growth and margins. I
expect your beta to change reflect the
third business you brought in. The one
difference between cost of capital when
you do capital budgeting where you stick
with the project and the company is you
got to be much more adaptable when you
look at a company because the company
itself can change. So I'm going to start
by estimating my cost of equity for
Deutsche Bank and Tarta Motors because
I'm doing an equity valuation of those
two companies. In early 2008 I used a
beta 1.16 for Deutsche Bank looking at
the average beta across commercial and
investment banks. And remember with
banks we don't unlever and relever betas
because debt is not a source of capital.
I used a risk-free rate in euros 4% then
and an equity risk premium reflecting
mature markets. My cost of equity for
DOce in 2008 was
9.23%. In euro terms with Tardam Motors,
I decided to do everything in repeat
terms. I start with a repeat riskree
rate of 6.57%. I know it's way back in
time, but the way I got it was I start
with an Indian government bond rate and
subtract out the default spread for
India. And when I did my cost of equity,
I brought in the beta for Tarta Motors,
reflecting automobile company betas and
an equity risk premium reflecting where
Tarta Motors got its revenues. You
remember China and India were competing
for the top spot. It's a weighted
average. It's that exact same. So you go
back and look at the capital budgeting
section, you'll see that same number in
the context of a hurdle rate. When we
looked at automotives for Disney, this
page actually is actually a complete
repeat of a page you saw at the start of
the capital structure section. It's
their existing cost of capital risk-free
rate 2.75%. It's T- bond rate. Beta is
the bottom of beta for Disney and the
equity risk premium reflects where
Disney makes its money with the
geographies. So my cost of equity is
8.52%. And my cost of capital if you
bring in the weighted average the cost
of debt which is 2.4% after taxes is
7.81%. I am using Disney's actual debt
ratio. If any of you have worked at
investment banks, there's often this big
debate that goes on within banks about
whether you should use an actual debt
ratio or a target debt ratio. The target
is kind of god knows where it comes
from. My suggestion is you always start
with the actual. Can you change it over
time? Absolutely. If you believe this
company's debt ratio is going to change
over time, and I'm going to make that
assumption. I will change the cost to
capital over time. So, when you do
discounted cash flow valuation, your
cost to capital is a number that should
vary across time for most companies
because your company is changing over
time. In fact, for Disney, here's what I
did. I didn't have much in terms of
change. The beta did was pretty close to
one. I think would stay close to one. I
did assume that over time the debt ratio
would go from 11 12% to 20%. And one of
the advantages of doing valuation or
corporate finance classes by the time
you get to the valuation section, you've
done your optimal capital structure,
right? You know that this companyy's
excess debt capacity. You can make a
judgment and whether the company will
use the debt capacity. I think Disney
will. So the debt ratio goes from 11 to
20%. And as the debt ratio changes, my
cost to capital, which starts at 7.81%,
the existing cost of capital will
decrease over time to 7.29%. So I want
to emphasize that because often in
discounted cash flow valuation, one of
the challenges you will face is people
think you get one shot at estimating the
cost of capital and it stays fixed over
time. But companies cost of capital
should change over time. Use that
adaptability.
So that's the big difference between
capital budgeting project where you have
one cost of capital. So with Disney
theme parks we stayed with one cost of
capital. You value a company with the
cost of capital can vary across time.
Any questions on c on either the cash
flow part of the discount
rates which brings us to expected
growth. There are three ways you can
estimate the growth for your company.
Easiest and the laziest way is look at
the past and just extrapolate. Let's
let's call that the chat GPT version,
right? Because anybody can do that. You
take the past, you just
extrapolate. The second is you ask
somebody
else what the growth rate will be. Any
ideas on who that somebody else might
be? Constantine, you're valing a
company. Who does somebody else could
ask?
You could ask the management, right? And
there is some basis for it. Do managers
know more about the company than you do?
Absolutely. You're saying, "Let me let
management tell me what the growth would
be." What are the downsides of doing
that though?
They could have no idea. Hopefully, they
have some idea. Otherwise, you're in big
trouble valuing the company. But even if
they do have an idea,
companies issue guidance
first. The in most cases when they give
guidance, how long-term is that
guidance? Next quarter. So, at the mo
for even when they give guidance, it's
shortterm. It's not long term. And when
they give long-term guidance, is there
some bias in what m absolutely right? So
you could ask management what the growth
rate is, but you have to take that with
not just a little bit of salt, but a
whole picture of salt, maybe a a bucket
full of salt. You know that when you do
private company valuation, you ask most
private company appraisers where they
get the numbers for the future. The
answer is we get them from management
forecast. have never understood how you
get away with it but it's become
established practice. So you can ask
management. Who else can you ask? I mean
you value I mean Kelly who are you
valuing
is Lululemon followed by a lot of equity
research analysts there probably 35 40
of them. They give of course forecast
for earnings for the next quarter but
they also some of them not all of them
and that's interesting about half of
them will give you fiveyear
forecasts and they give fiveyear
forecasts. Which metric usually are they
forecasting?
revenues, operating income. I would love
for it to be revenue. I wish it usually
they forecast earnings per share. For
some reason, they're very focused on
earnings per share. They give revenue
forecast very rarely because they're not
thinking of business model. They think
about the bottom line. But there is
there are growth rates and you can say
look, they follow the company all the
time. So they must know more about
Lululemon than I do. So you're basically
saying I'm going to use the analyst
forecast of growth. So you can look at
the past, you can outsource your growth
rate. But ultimately for a company to
grow, it has to do something, right?
Can't I mean I can't go around endowing
companies with high growth just because
I feel like it. And there are two things
that a company has to to do to grow. And
as I list the two, you're already going
to see what limits growth at a company.
One is remember we looked at the
reinvestment
rate which is the portion of your of
your earnings you put back into the
company and as you did that as I did
that you said as an investor why are you
doing it you're reducing my cash flows
I'm doing it because one of the pillars
on which growth is built is how much are
you reinvesting it's very difficult for
a company that reinvests very little to
grow a lot in the
future so what does reinvestment mean
you're taking your money and you're
putting into projects does it matter
what kind of projects you
take. You know, in capital budgeting, we
want to take good projects. Do good
projects. How do we define good
projects? They either have positive net
present value. We use the shortcut that
the return on capital is greater than
the cost of
capital. There are two things you need
to do. You need to reinvest a lot and
reinvest well at the same time. And
already you can see why companies can
pull off one half of the equation but
don't succeed with the other. There are
lots of companies that reinvest a
lot but don't reinvest well. There are a
lot of companies that reinvest well but
don't reinvest very so getting both
sides of that equation going is tough to
do. It's easy to grow fast. It's really
difficult to have quality growth because
you need to pull that off. So the third
way in which we're going to estimate
growth is we're going to look at the
company's fundamentals. How much is it
reinvesting? How well is it
reinvesting? Disney, I gave you a sense
of how much was reinvesting, right? At
least based on 2013, it's reinvesting
about
54%. Do you have a sense of how well
Disney is
reinvesting? When we did capital
budgeting, we did that tangent. We look
at the return on capital of Disney of
12.61% higher than the cost of capital.
If they can maintain that return on
capital, we now have the basis for
making a judgment at least of whether
Disney can continue to
grow. So we're going to look at the
fundamentals of a company to decide
whether it can keep growing. At a
generic level though, I'm going to go
through a process and this is the
spreadsheet you're going to use because
I don't want you reinventing the wheel
in building your own valuation
spreadsheet in the last two weeks of
this class. And this spreadsheet is not
going to become a black box. I promise
you cuz it's built on three drivers of
business models and I want to talk about
all three drivers. The first is revenue
growth. We talked about Tesla making
small revenues become bigger revenues.
What drives revenue growth? We'll talk
about the inputs that drive that. The
second is what kind of margins will you
make as a company over time? And the
third is how much will you need to
reinvest to deliver that revenue growth.
Every business model I'm going to argue
can be boiled down to those three
metrics. and we'll talk about what
drives those three metrics. So if you
have a company with stable growth and
sta stable returns and stable margins,
I'll give you a shortcut to get the
growth rate. But use it only if you have
stable margins. And for most companies,
it's a really tough call to
make. So let's talk about the generic
way in which you can go about estimating
cash flows. And as I said the the the
spreadsheet it's called FCF Ginsu simple
Ginsu. Basically it's a spreadsheet that
tries to bring it all together. It's
built upon three levers. First is I'm
going to ask you what revenue growth
yeah for your company. Your first
reaction is going to be I've never
valued a company. I have no idea. That's
not true. By the time you get to this
you've looked at your company for 12
weeks in the context of capital
structure dividend. You have a sense at
least. Is this a high growth company an
average growth company or a low growth
company? I'll give you some things to
look at to make that judgment, but
that's going to make your revenues
change over time. Second question I'm
going to ask you is tell me what kind of
margins this company will make in the
future. For some of your companies,
those margins can be very similar to
today's margins. It's in steady state.
You're valuing Costco, your margins are
not going to change dramatically over
time. It's an established company.
You're valing Chipotle, your margins
might not change very much over time.
You're valuing Carava, your margins
might change. It's a high growth
Mediterranean fast food chain. Its
margins might evolve over time. And you
say margins going forward will improve
because of economies of
scale. Going to talk about estimating
margin. The third input is given your
revenue growth, I'm going to hold you
accountable. And here's what what I mean
by holding you accountable. Now, often I
talk to founders about their business
and ask them what kind of revenue growth
do you expect? What what do you think
the answer is? High. Right? They say
okay. 80% a year. Yeah, that's good.
Even 120% a year, you say, "Okay, let me
give you the bill." To grow 120% a year,
what do you have to do? You have to
reinvest a lot. And if you're a founder,
what does reinvesting a lot mean? You
got to go raise capital from venture
capitalist. And what are they going to
demand in
return? A share of your business. And
already you can see why bringing this up
is going to sober founders on how much
growth they want. Because to get 120%
growth, you might have to give up 80% of
your company. Say, look, I don't want to
do that. Okay, then let's bring the
growth down to 60% or 40%. Anytime you
have a discussion about growth, you've
got to bring in a discussion of what you
have to reinvest to generate that
growth. Otherwise, revenue growth just
becomes unconstrained. You're going to
use whatever number you want to use to
get to whatever value you want. Growth,
margins, reinvestment. So, I want you to
think about your company and already
start to think about those pieces
because each one I'm going to list some
of the things you're going to look at to
make a
judgment. So, Patrick, I want to pick
your company for for this. Who who you
value? Otherwise,
okay, so let's start with revenue
growth, right? First, is it is the
market it's going after a growing market
or pretty mature market? Pretty mature
market and Monalay is already a big
player in that market, right? It's put a
pretty big market share already. You can
see that your revenue growth is probably
going to be more singledigit than double
digit because you can't grow very fast
if you have a 30% or 25% market share of
a mature market. But if you are doing
this for a much smaller food company,
let's take Celsius small beverage
company. So Coca-Cola I can't do much in
growth but Celsius I might say look it's
a small company the market is big. You
can take market share away. So, you're
going to look at the size of the market
and how much it's growing. And you're
also going to look at your company's
market
share and whether that market share will
change over
time. Any of you doing a high growth
company? You want to throw it in the
mix? You can be a money-making company
that's high growth,
right? No. Nobody doing a high growth
company. Somebody must be doing a
company where the market itself is
growing.
If you have a market that's growing,
that gives you some leeway to have a
growth rate. Apple and Samsung in 2010
had big market shares of the smartphone
market, but they were able to grow 15% a
year because the smartphone market was
itself still growing. Today, you look at
Apple and Samsung, you're not going to
be giving them double-digit growth
anymore because the smartphone market
has leveled off. You can look at the
total market and how much it's growing.
And you can look at your market share.
And as you look at the market share, you
also have to explore what I call the
industry economics. How is this
business going to end up looking?
Right? Businesses can either be
splintered businesses. We have multiple
players each taking small market shares.
They can be winner take all
businesses. And it's not something you
pick. It's basically a business
characteristic. But over time,
businesses can evolve. 30 years ago, if
you looked at the advertising business,
hopelessly splintered
business, largest advertising company in
the world might have had a 2% market
share. Why? Because it was newspapers
and billboards that were localized,
geographically
constrained. Today, two companies
dominate that market. The two companies
are Facebook and Google, right? Online
advertising has changed the economics of
the advertising business. car
service 30 years ago biggest car service
company in the world might have been a
taxi cap company in New York City with
a.3% market share of the global car
service business today Uber andyft are
increasing and DD and the other ride
sharing companies technology has allowed
businesses that used to be splintered to
become more winner take all businesses
Airbnb in the hospitality business is
able to do things that a single hotel
company could
So as you look at industry economics,
those are the some of the things you
might want to explore. And finally, your
company has to be doing something that's
going to allow it to increase its market
share, right? And this is where with
companies like Lululemon, you start to
think about what is their what do you
think their biggest competitive
advantages?
Their brand, right? And the problem is
brands age over time. So Lululemon is no
longer a young growing brand. They're an
aging brand and everybody's coming after
you and in business and you see the same
thing with Nike, right? One of the great
brand names of all time eventually
brand. So as you look at your company,
all of those things play out and what
kind of growth you're going to give for
your company. Any questions about
revenue
growth? Ask your final question. Could
your revenue growth for your company be
negative? Do some companies shrink over
time? Yeah. So clearly revenue growth
can be negative. So let's look at what
has to come through for a company to
have shrinking revenues a minus 5%
revenue growth for the next 10 years
which I allow in the
spreadsheet. So what kind of companies
do you think will have negative revenue
growth?
Yes. One is you take a company like
Altria Philip Morris and you say look
the entire business is shrinking your
market is aging.
And you could say, I'm going to give
Altria to Philip Morris a minus 3%
growth over the next 10 years. Brick and
mortar retail companies, mine, my base
inclination is to give you a negative
revenue growth rate unless you're
special, right? Costco, I might give a
positive growth rate, saying, but for
most brick and mortar retail companies,
I'm saying this is a business that's
shrinking. If you're in a market that's
shrinking, there's nothing wrong with
giving your company a negative growth
rate. One of the first questions I ask
when I talk to appraisers and our
analysts is ask them when was the last
time you valued a company where you had
negative growth for the next 5 or 10
years. You know what the answer often
is? I've never done it. And that gives
you something about the psychological
barrier to putting in a negative number.
It just seems unnatural. But leave that
door open if your company is potentially
a negative growth company. You could
argue that companies like Coca-Cola and
McDonald's looking long-term are looking
at shrinking businesses rather than
growing
businesses because of what they sell and
what kind of business model they have.
So that's the first stop is revenue
growth. Any questions on revenue growth?
Then let's talk about operating margins.
Let's look at the drivers of operating
margins. The first is unit economics.
What is unit economics? It basically
looks at the next unit you sell and how
much you make on that next
unit. Let's do a contrast here, right?
Let's take Tesla, their electric car
business. What is unit economics? To
sell a car, they first have to make it.
So the cost to making the car becomes
part of the cost you got to cover. So
already you can see unit economics are
going to reflect that cost.
The the number that captures this best
in an accounting statement is your gross
margin. Basically, if you look at a
company with a gross margin of 80, 85,
90%. The unit economics are amazing. But
if you look at manufacturing companies,
the gross margin is going to be 20 25
30%. Not because they're bad companies,
but because you got to make the damn
thing first before you sell it. Software
companies have high operating margins
simply because unit economics in
software are to sell the extra unit. You
don't even have to make it, right? It's
free. Everything is
gravy. So if you look at your company,
say what kind of unit economics, think
about what your company
does. Manderlay has to make stuff before
they sell it. The only advantage is I
don't know what the cost of what they
make is, but it's a fraction of what
they sell it for. Much of it is SGNA and
advertising costs. I don't know what
Lululemon spends making their apparel,
but the number that'll give this away is
look at your gross margins. So if your
gross margins are 50, 60, 70%, you got
great unit economics. You can give your
company high operating
margins. No, which brings me to Nvidia.
Know what Nvidia's gross margins are?
It's the highest I've ever seen of a
large
company. It's 80% gross margins. How
does a It's a manufacturing company.
Tech is it though? It's a chip company,
but it's doesn't even make its own
chips.
TSMC makes them. It's a design. It's
more like a software company in terms of
what it does. It designs the chips. It
makes TSMC. It TSMC makes the chips and
it marks them up
900%. And who does it sell it to? Where
its biggest
customers, Meta and Microsoft, right?
How the hell do you pull this off? See,
because you see the pressures on both
sides, right? If you're at TSMC, my
question is why aren't you asking for a
bigger slice of the pie and if you met
in Microsoft you're saying why am I
paying this 900% market? Why are they
right
now? Because they've been told that the
only way you build an AI data center is
with these high power chips and Nvidia
is the only player in town for the
moment. Will that change? Absolutely. So
if you're valing invidia, you see what's
coming, right? The margins to begin with
can stay 50 55 60 65% but over time
there is going to be pressure. Margins
are not going to go down to 3%. But
they're not going to stay at
65%. That's what I mean by stories
connecting to numbers. So when I look at
Nvidia valuation I see 70% to start and
60% the end. The question I'm asking is
what's happening to your company? Why
are your margins decreasing? And the
story you'll tell is I'm getting
pressure from both sides. manufacturing
from TSMC and from my customers to lower
my prices and that's playing out as
lower margins.
Second, economies of scale. Great
buzzword. One of the easiest way when
you do a valuation, you increase your
margin. Say economies of scale. Who can
who can argue with that? But what does
that mean? Economies of scale. Somebody
give me a something which is less
abstract than a buzz word. What does it
mean when you have economies of scale?
As your revenues grow, your costs don't
grow proportionately. they grow less
than your revenue. That's at the S,
right? So, if a company claims it is
economies of scale, what is the first
way you can check to see whether that's
true? Look at the history. If their
revenues have grown 18% a year and their
costs have also grown 18% a year, you're
going to say, "What economies of
scale. If there are economies of scale,
you should see the cost items that that
that are part of that economies of scale
grow at a slower rate than the revenues
are. Are they business with economies of
scale?
Absolutely. But there are limits to
economies of scale. Let me explain. If
you're valuing Chipotle and your margins
right now are like 16%, which is where
they are, and you make them go to 25% in
your valuation, they say economies of
scale, I'm going to push back on you.
Chipotle is already a big company. When
you get that big, your economies of
scale start to run out of steam. If
you're a small restaurant company you're
doing cover and you say look I think
economies of scale are going to improve
margins I'm willing to listen it's a
small so when you talk about economies
of scale factor in whether much of it is
already happen or whether you have a
runway ahead of you third all too often
you have people say costs are going to
go down therefore my margins will
increase this is the AI story I keep
hearing for companies right grocery
stores are going to become more
profitable why because they will use AI
to reduce their cost of inventory and
other what's the flaw in the story let's
say it's true that AI will reduce your
cost of doing business why might it not
play out as higher margins
the cost of AI the cost of AI and the
other thing is if everybody has AI
what's going to happen all grocery
stores are going to have lower costs and
the nature of the business universe is
if everybody has lower cost guess Who
ends up benefiting from those lower
costs? It's customers. Right? This is
why the internet did not improve the
profitability of every company. Social
media didn't improve this. It's there
are people who will make money on AI.
But I can almost guarantee you for the
rest of the world, it's going to become
a cost and I'm not sure it's going to
show up as higher margins because if
everybody has it, nobody has it because
effectively you can't take advantage of
it. So if I hear about a cost going
down, I want to also hear your story
about why it's going down just for your
company. Maybe it's proprietary AI that
works only at your company. Then I'm
willing to listen to that improving
margins. So all of those things go into
your target margin. And second, you got
to tell me how quickly you will get
there. So let's say your margins right
now are 4%. Your target margin is 10%.
You can get from 4 to 10 next year, 4 to
10. Does it make a difference?
Absolutely. But whether you will get
there slowly or quickly will depend on
what kind what the management is focused
on. If the management is focused on
growth first, I can almost guarantee you
that speed with which you move to your
margins is going to be slower because
they're going to be focused on growing
growing and then worrying about margins
later. Your business model will matter
and the tradeoffs that the business
makes will drive how quickly you move
it. So one of the inputs you would see
in that in that Ginsa spreadsheet is
when will you reach your target margin
say how the heck do I know look at your
company look at what they're focused on
if they're growth focused and their
business model is going to be slow to
adjust it might take a much longer time
to get to your margins but your margin
matters and you can't arbitrarily take a
manufacturing company and give it 60%
margin just because you like the company
I love Costco as a company I don't think
its margins will ever exceed need 6 or
7%. It's a great company at 7% margins.
It it is under it's undervalued as a
company, but it can't get to 30, 40,
50%. It's not that kind of
business. There's one aspect of Costco
though where their margins could
potentially be higher. How many of you
are Costco
members? Lot of services. Have you
noticed a lot more services now that you
can get through Costco? No. You can get
your roof replaced, your air
conditioning. Those service businesses
are higher margin businesses for Costco
than their traditional retail
business. Costco travel, you know, I do
all my car rentals through Costco. I get
great rates. That's a much higher margin
business. If you're telling a value, if
you're telling a story about Costco
where they're service business is
growing, you could actually argue that
that could push up their margins over
time. But that's the kind of thing
that'll allow you to push margins up
from what the traditional margins have
been to a higher number. And the key
word is story. Explain to me what you
think will happen to your company that
justifies those higher
margins. Which brings me to the third
and final input. And this will be the
toughest one for you because it doesn't
have the
intuitive link that both revenue growth
and margins have. Remember I said to
grow you got to
reinvest. The sales to capital connects
your revenue forecast to your
reinvestment or intuitively if you want
to grow your revenues a lot I'm going to
ask you to set aside more money in
whatever you need to do to grow. So if
you're a manufacturing company to grow
your revenues what do you have to do you
got to build assembly plants man you
know factories equipment if you're a
pharmaceutical company and you want to
grow what do you have to do you have to
invest more in R&D so it doesn't have to
be the same item but I'm looking for
reinvestment and to connect your revenue
growth reinvestment I'm look at I'm
going to look at a ratio of revenues to
invested capital that invested capital
is exactly the same invested capital we
talked about in the context of a return
invested capital but in numerator here I
look at revenues the way to read this
number if your sales invested capital is
three for every dollar you invest you
get $3 in revenues so you're a company
that's very efficient low capital
intensity company you should get lots of
revenues per dollar of capital
invested if you're a company with huge
capital investments you're an
infrastructure company you're going to
have a much lower sales to capital ratio
so again you can't just sit there and
make up a number it depends on the
business you're
But there are a couple of caveats I
would add. You can look at your
company's history in terms of sales to
invested capital. Yesterday I was
looking at a valuation that somebody
sent me for a real estate company in the
Middle East with a sales to invested
capital of 3. My first reaction is if
you leave the sales to capital ratio at
3 0 this company is going to crash and
burn. You can see why right? If your
sales to capital is 0, what's happening?
You invest a dollar in capital, you get
30 cents in revenues. Already everything
else is going to start to look terrible.
So you're saying, but that's a history.
You're right. That's a history. They've
been building a lot of real estate
developments, but as this is one of
those case where as you grow as a
company, your sales to capital ratio
should improve because you'll be able to
live off investments you made in the
past. So when you look at your company,
look at the sales to capital ratio.
going to look at their you know the
their scaling effects you're also going
to look at whether there's excess
capacity talk about another valuation I
got a valuation of Boeing that I got
yesterday they put I I think the revenue
growth used for Boeing for the next 10
years is about 15% at least in this
valuation you think that's really high
you know why the 15% actually is not
unreasonable Boeing in 2024 sold fewer
aircraft than they did in 2019 or 2015.
The company's had a really bad 10 years
and you don't need to ask me why because
you can look at the history of you know
all kinds of bad things have happened at
the company many
self-inflicted. So what this valuation
was effectively doing was taking those
low revenues in 2024 and bringing them
back to 2019 revenue. So it wasn't even
a growth to some new level. It's just
selling as many aircraft as they did in
2019. You say how are they going to pull
this off? There only two players in this
game, right? Boeing and
Airbus. And I promise you, Airbus is
going to have its own problems because
this is, you know, one company goes
through problems, the other does. So
that so the growth I said that makes
sense. And then I got to the sales to
capital ratio and they' use Boeing's
historic sales to capital ratio to
require a huge amount of reinvestment.
That part doesn't hold up. And here's
why. Bo, what's Boing going to do?
Produce as many aircraft as they did in
2009. They already have the capacity to
do that. They got almost free growth for
the next few years because they can live
off excess capacity. Cruise line
companies after they came out of 2020,
many of them you could put high revenue
growth rate, no investment needed
because you already had the cruise
ships. So look at excess capacity and
whether the company can get away with
that excess capacity. When I value Tesla
two years ago, right after they finished
their Shangghai plant, I gave them a
high sales to capital ratio at least for
the next 5 years because they built
enough capacity to be able to grow
without building new plans for the next
few
years. And finally, in some businesses,
there is a lag between when you invest
and when you see
growth. Give my favorite example, Novo
Nordisk. Is it having high growth right
now? kind of not as high as people
thought it was two years ago, but still
high. Coming from
what? Wiggoi and Olympic, right? Do they
need to reinvestigate that
growth? No. Wiggoi and Ompic were
created from R&D done 10 years ago. With
farmer companies, what you're going to
get as growth in the next 10 years will
reflect reinvestment made in the last 10
years.
Which means when you project growth out
for these companies, you can have a high
sales gap ratio, low reinvestment
because they've already done the bulk of
the reinvestment. Same thing with
infrastructure companies, you invest
first and then you grow. You can get
that mismatch between revenue growth and
reinvestment because of the kind of
companies. So if nothing else, open I'll
send you the link to the the valuation
spreadsheet. Open it up and at least
start thinking. Don't put numbers down
until you've started thinking about your
company and the things we talked about
and then start to enter the numbers
because your story will drive your
numbers. I will see you on Wednesday.